- La surprise est totale
au Kansas.
Cet État conservateur,
traditionnel bastion
des anti-avortement,
a dit non à un changement
de la constitution de l'État.
Près de 60 % des électeurs
ont refusé que ce droit
à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse soit restreint,
voire éliminé.
"Je suis très fière d'être
du Kansas, dit Elie Hatley.
La campagne pendant ce
référendum fut des plus intenses
pour convaincre l'électorat.
Et contre toute attente,
elle a permis de jauger
la mobilisation des partisans
démocrates et progressistes,
mais pas que.
"La victoire a été obtenue,
dit Ashley All, grâce à une
coalition d'électeurs de droite
et de gauche qui ont dit
non à ces politiques extrêmes.
Les républicains locaux
dénoncent ce qu'ils ont appelé
la campagne de peur orchestrée
par les pro-choix.
Ceux qui ont fait campagne pour
les restrictions à l'avortement
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot.
"Les pro-choix, dit-il, se sont
acheté juste un peu de temps."
Depuis que la Cour suprême a
invalidé le droit à l'avortement
et laissé le choix aux États
de légiférer en la matière,
les démocrates fourbissent
leurs armes en vue des élections
de mi-mandat de novembre
prochain. L'enjeu de l'accès
à l'avortement semble porteur.
Cette semaine, le Département
de la justice a poursuivi
l'État de l'Idaho qui s'est doté
d'une loi des plus restrictives.
"Cette loi, dit-il, viole une
loi fédérale sur les urgences
médicales auxquelles font face
les femmes qui doivent
se faire avorter."
Et puis, pour la deuxième fois
en quelques semaines, Joe Biden
a signé un décret présidentiel
pour garantir un accès
à l'avortement.
Cette fois-ci, pour garantir
que les femmes qui voyagent à
l'extérieur de leur État pour
obtenir un avortement puissent
avoir accès aux services
de santé appropriés.
Une dizaine d'États ont déjà
banni les avortements sur
leur sol. Et à terme, la moitié
des 50 États, forcément
républicains, feront de même.
Le résultat de ce référendum
mettra-t-il un frein aux ardeurs
des anti-avortement?
Les démocrates espèrent
en tout cas que le réveil
des progressistes au Kansas
s'étendra un peu partout et leur
sera bénéfique dans moins de
100 jours, lorsque la majorité
des sièges au Congrès seront
remis en jeu.
Ici, Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, à Washington